the Indian Capital Delhi routinely ranks
as one of the world's most polluted
cities its air quality alternates
routinely between hazardous and
unhealthy look at the weather app on
your phone and you'll see what I mean
but it's especially bad in October and
November each year a seasonal mix of
factors such as stubble burning by
Farmers vehicular emissions and weather
patterns literally cause people to choke
every winter a dense smog descends on
the Indian Capital making the lives of
it some 20 million residents miserable
as in previous years the toxic air poses
a major health risk to the stees
children
Ruchi manjal is very concerned about her
three-year-old daughter Anika who
suffers from shortness of breath and a
severe cough we take help of medicines
at times we have the visits to the
doctors are very constant these days for
children of this age group so the
situation is not at all good
the family was even forced to buy ear
purifiers to help the air quality at
home
the situation has also become critical
in the capital schools after a week up
no classes this Delhi primary school is
open today despite the high level of
pollution but while classes have resumed
there is still a complete ban on outdoor
activities
a senior teacher says that toxic smog in
Delhi puts her students at grave risk
the majority of the children suffer from
severe coughs and sometimes even faint
but the schools face a dilemma as a
teacher the biggest challenge is the
students health is very important which
we are trying to maintain and second
biggest thing is that we don't want the
schools to be shot at this time again
because the two years pandemic has
actually deteriorated the education
quality of the school and the students
as well according to the latest report
from state of global year more than 100
000 infants in India died within a month
of birth due to a pollution another
study has shown that one in every three
children in Delhi has impaired lung
function
this Hospital in New Delhi is
experiencing a surge of patients because
of the Ski's toxic air
pulmonologist Dr nikhil Modi has seen
hundreds of patients mostly children
suffering from respiratory problems
he says that situation is alarming
and believes that delhi's toxic ear
could trigger a serious health crisis
children is a very very vulnerable group
because they are young their lungs are
still in the development phase so during
the development due to the exposure to
so much of pollution their lung before
getting developed can get damaged and
that damage can be permanent
Indian government is currently working
on an ambitious clean air program
aims to cut air pollution by 40 over the
next five years
but that is a long wait for children
like an ICA who's already suffering from
breathing problems
let's get more on this from Jyoti Pandey
alavakare she's a journalist and author
of breathing here is injurious to your
health a book about air pollution in
India
your uh you have lived in Delhi quite
for quite some time which ranks as one
of the world's most polluted cities what
is it like to spend a day in delhi's
polluted air
uh it's awful it's actually like smoking
involuntarily uh your eye sting your
throat just clasped and starts hurting
you get sore throats you get sick really
often I get a dull pollution headache
pretty much every time I step out
um it's really bad it's actually a human
rights violation
it's quite a thing to say a human rights
violation but this happens particularly
every winter in Delhi because it faces
this thick blanket of smog that
virtually shuts everything down and it's
caused by stubble burning on farms
vehicular emissions and construction
dust the question is why does this keep
happening every year and why is it not
preventable
uh it is preventable actually uh and uh
the pandemic the lockdown through the
pandemic showed us how it is indeed
reversible as well uh when we saw Clear
Blue Skies clean clean air in the
winters of uh the kobit the two years
that we were locked in for covid but let
me just quickly try and explain why this
repeats itself every single winter what
happens is in North India there is the
Himalayan range which sort of acts as a
barrier to dissipate um air pollution
especially the most uh
harmful particles this the tiny
microscopic PM 2.5 particles what
happens in the winter is when
temperatures come down there is
something called inversion where air
pollution gets trapped closer to the
ground so we are seeing more dense uh
micro particulate matter which we then
end up smoking because we I really can't
call it breathing breathing is an
involuntary activity and when you're
constantly smoking
smoke and dust then really it is a human
rights pollution we turn Deli turn then
most of North India actually I don't
want to make this about Delhi the entire
indogangetic pain starts smoking and
that's 510 million people who are pretty
much in a gas chamber for most of the
winter
so the way you describe it it sounds a
lot like a climatic phenomenon how do
you prevent that
so it's not just uh this is this is I
only uh touched upon the geographic and
meteorological reasons what happens in
the winter is when Farmers start start
burning their crop stubble that releases
a lot of smoke and the winds are turning
around that time so the smoke comes
downwind all the way to all the dense
Urban centers also at that time October
and November is when India sees its
largest Festival the Festival of Diwali
which is festival of lights but seems to
have become the Festival of firecrackers
so you have like about a billion people
bursting firecrackers and even if
everybody says well I'll just burst a
few you can imagine what sort of
pollution there is in the air not just
micro particulate matter by now because
this has barium nitrates all sorts of
chemicals so now you're smoking
chemicals in addition to the carbon
particles that you're inhaling and these
lead to episodic highs which actually
Hospital admissions in the winter have
shown to have risk to to rise sharply
every single winter and despite that I
don't think this is getting the kind of
public attention or governmental
attention that it needs you know I did
want to talk to you about the
governmental attention but just the way
you describe it it almost sounds like
people themselves don't care enough to
stop doing the things that they are
doing that are contributing to this kind
of Illusion would you agree
so I think there isn't as much awareness
and a you know if I were to give an
example when kovid first started not
many people were aware of what this
disease is and how that it harms us and
all of that but the government is very
good it it very quickly spread this
information through phone calls you
couldn't make a phone call without
getting the pre-recorded message on what
covet is and how it harms you and how to
protect yourself nothing like this has
happened for air pollution which
actually kills many more people air
pollution is killing almost 2 million
people uh every year in India and that's
many more than kovit does and yet it
isn't treated as a public health
emergency which it undoubtedly is air
pollution actually is the most harmful
it causes more harm than
um disease and uh sorry than war or you
know any kind of even smoking it's it's
way up there as the most harmful Public
Health Emergency and yet it is not given
that attention by the government
all right so what is the awareness part
of it what about uh other Solutions
you're also co-founder of an NGO care
for air in your line of work are you
seeing enough solutions that uh people
are working on
yes there are people who are coming up
with innovative solutions but you know
you really need in a situation like this
you can't have a small number of people
working in silos with innovative
solutions you really need the entire
force of the government and the
corporate sector there is a lot of
industrial pollution there is a lot of
vehicular pollution we have crops double
burning which is completely avoidable
and which contributes almost 44 of
winter air pollution to the north parts
of the country and that is completely
avoidable uh you also have things like
firecrackers which in fact my group uh
the uh supreme court lawyer who's one of
the co-founders of my group petitioned
to the Supreme Court and had banned from
2017 1819 but despite that of course
enforcement is not strong enough so you
have people despite it being unlawful
and illegal reverse firecrackers going
ahead and doing that because they are
not aware of how how badly it's
affecting them their young ones and
their previous generation
we leave it there for the time being but
thank you so much for joining us today